If you want to experience weaving and pottery skills,...
...a visit to the Bishnoi villages in India is a great way to spend a day.
The trip should take six to eight hours and a four-wheel-drive taxi...
...can be booked at travel agents in Jodhpur.
When you arrive at the scattered villages,...
...you will see the people living in thatched houses with vegetable gardens,...
...tending their herds of goats and camels.
Camel hair is used to weave beautiful dhurries,...
...which are rugs dyed with vegetable colors.
In addition, while there is a chance to buy some wonderful pottery,...
...you can also try your hand at it.
Why not create your own masterpiece there?
A good route would be to start out at Gudda Bishnoi and Mogra...
...to check out the weaving process.
There are plenty of dhabas,...
...which are refreshment stops in the local language on the way,...
...and the hotel in Rohet is a great stop for lunch.